[Musique]
le gymnase de la fraternité de la
verrière a accueilli le premier tournoi
à dos des sites et fantastique des
yvelines co-organisé par le réalisateur
verrier roanne à dire yul un entre jeu
vidéo et balle au prisonnier ado est un
sport d'équipé en réalité augmentée
venus du japon les communes des yvelines
engagées contre les noyades première
cause de mortalité par accidents chez
les moins de 25 ans plusieurs stages de
natation étaient proposés pendant les
vacances de printemps et notamment à
saint cyr l'école une nouvelle vie pour
l'ancien relais de poste de joueur pour
chartrain le gué relais est désormais un
espace de coworking 500 m² d'espacés
aménagés qui héberge déjà une dizaine de
coworkers coût total de la rénovation
2,5 millions d'euros l'ancien maire de
mantes-la-jolie agressé raphaël cogné a
été frappé par trois hommes qui ont vidé
également sur lui le contenu d'un
extincteur des faits qui se sont
produits dans le quartier du val fourré
touchés par des épisodes de violences
cette semaine et ce en plein contexte de
l'élection municipale partielle des 15
et 22 mai pour laquelle raphaël commis
est candidat il a porté plainte et reçu
de nombreux soutiens dans celui du
préfet des yvelines jean jacques brot
qui a condamné cette agression et puis
un tournoi international de parra tennis
de table a démarré jeudi au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
près de 400 points gist de l'élite
mondiale sont de la partie avec
plusieurs médaillés des derniers jeux
paralympiques de tokyo